l'arrivée imminente des joueurs beaucoup
de flash garry kasparov et arié garry
kasparov et la directrice pas aux
fellahs un peu dans la salle il a dit
l'air kramnik ne va pas tarder et
l'admirent ramené il va aller dans son
coin
c'est un vrai match de boxe voilà la
tanière et là on vous l'a dit mercredi
contre garry kasparov voilà ils se
serrent la main sa soeur la même mais
c'est beaucoup entendu que la deuxième
il y avait des sourires là à la grille
kasparov ou là il arbore une tête
extrêmement méchant qu'il a l'air
déterminé ou et chronicart un si petit
soulier al di meola ou là là là on sent
que les joueurs sont très très tendue
aujourd'hui là ça a vraiment ils sont
pas venus là pour rigoler rana les
précieux qui lui dit le regard las
kasparov au g10 attendant tu y as tu as
voulu jouer en valais donc la voir tu
vas voir ce que tu vas voir la houlala
oulalala il a pas l'air il a pas l'air
de vouloir jouer sa tranquille
déclenchement des pendules ah là là
alors je prends que je vais aller je
vais aller voilà heureusement quelqu'un
est là pour pour maintenir un peu
l'ordre
garry kasparov joue le coup e 2 e 4
c'est parti ça commence c'est parti
va-t-il affronter de nouveau une has
c'est là il à y rejouer 4 heroes leucate
donc il met la pression sur kramnik
vas-y vas-y rejoins moi ta berlinoise
rejoue la moi tu vas voir ce que tu vas
voir donc eu 2 e 4 k était joué e24 a
été jouée e75 ça y est ramenée rejoue la
berlinoise greul a pas peur la panique
il a pas peur alors là ça va être ça va
être serré derrière des nerfs
vraisemblablement kasparov a joué
cavalier f3 wen au même jeu l'écossaise
il va jouer les cons c'est sûr non ils
ne gagnaient des coureurs il va rejouer
fou b5 pas disons que ça se passe le
problème c'est que si on joue pas il
faut que le sexe est un aveu de
faiblesse tout à fait escale dans les
matches c'est très connu
voilà nous refaisons le cadre là ça y
est parfait garry kasparov en pleine
méditation
ah la la la ces c'est un grand moment de
ce championnat du monde fou mais c'est
un coup des quatre kasparov
acculé dès le début du match peut-être
même déjà obligé de changer son
ouverture fétiche objet de ne pas jouer
au foot b5
c'est à dire la variante rui lopez il va
peut-être jouer d2 d4 c'est un moment
très important de cette partie le choix
de garry kasparov ou b 5e et nous allons
assister à une berlinoise a noté l'air
incroyable de garry kasparov qui n'est
vraiment pas content alors là c'est ça
c'est important c'est un moment très
important du match
c'est un moment très important du match
puisque la kasparov rejoue la même
ouverture qu'il avait joué dimanche de
l'année mercredi qu'avait joué à ce
moment là le l'autre cavaliers sur la
case f6 est donc là il re propose à
kramnik deux jours la même chose
il lui dit vas-y joue pareil il joue
pareil et oui kramnik n'a pas peur de la
parole dit vas-y vas-y tu t'inquiètes
pas j'ai tout calculé passant je vous la
même variante wallon là c'est un moment
extrêmement important du match parce que
si kasparov n'arrive pas à gagner cette
ouverture
il est dans la boîte est loin s'ils ne
passent pas effectivement il sera il
saura mal kasparov a priori voilà ou
alors ils vont répéter les coups petit
rock voilà tout ça c'est très normal
garry kasparov répète les coûts là une
longue va renforcer s'annonce trame
unique devrait jouer assez rapidement
voilà les coups sont échangés la
validité théâtre donc la n va jouer tes
des deux gares je pense qu'il va
vraisemblablement le rejouer ça paraît
quasiment certain qu'il va jouer là ça y
est il est où il donnait cardy ajouté
deux décades donc heroes et répète la
partie de dimanche
il répète la partie de dimanche cram
nick va répéter également cavalier des
six voilà ça y est c'est fait qu'avec
des six ils sont en train de rejouer
exactement la même chose
kasparov a prononcé six a l'air d'être
une certitude après fou prince et six
pions dame prince et six et ensuite
l'avion prend un sel car cramique avait
joué cavalier f5 alors on va voir si ça
va être pareil cas ce parent faut voir
dans la tête de kasparov
voilà je pense qu'il ya à faire des gros
plan sur cette ouverture voilà quelle
star of a
je jette un oeil à regret et je vous
faut penser il faut prendre ces six très
logique in april faut prendre ces six
kasparov la répondu le coup logique la
reprise du pied de la dame encore une
fois qu'ils ont prend 1,5 et alors mais
s'il répète la même partie kasparov ces
parties nulles l'oeil droit
s'il répète la même chose c'est
effectivement partie nulle la question
est de savoir qui va changer en premier
parce que les deux joueurs ont
évidemment un cabinet la partie à moins
que les lois il est comme ils ont fait
partie de l'avant la sphère peut-être
kasparov a vu qu'ils pouvaient gagner
non non je ne pense pas il vient de
jouer d'un programme quand monique va
jouer au wap renvoi c'est aussi ça y est
c'est fait seul coup légal dans la
position puisque le roi est un échange
tout l'enjeu de cette partie c'est qui
va changer en premier garry kasparov
s'est brûlé encore pareil qui avait
laissé 3 et la chronique avec juifs ou
des 7,6 g j avais je me fous des fêtes
un coup un peu atypique
alors peut-être que maintenant au kram
nique dans cette position inchangée ne
va pas je me fous des sept et non de
cette chronique est sûr de lui larry
trailer de lui pour l'instant cela même
parti il va falloir qu'à un moment donné
les deux joueurs changent alors surtout
kasparov kramnik ans que des terres à
changer rapidement non attention
rappelons nous de ce match contre
allende qui avait été une leçon pour
tous les joueurs d'échecs b2 b3 ga sport
joue pareil
waouh alors là c'est plus tout à fait la
même chose quand même puisque la
dernière fois qu à ce moment fait avait
déjà réfléchi très longtemps pour que
cette position c'est à une première
différence
ah oui là il a préparé ça là il a
préparé ça c'est sûr la chronique
qu'est ce qui alors qu'est-ce qu'il a
joué là il avait joué h6 joue pareil
tout à fait joue pareil le bras de fer
est engagé
garry kasparov va jouer tous les deux
est-ce que c'est pas risqué pour kramnik
là est-ce qu'il faut qu'ils foutent des
deux mais c'est incroyable ça
kasparov avait dit quand on a gagné une
partie ans quand on est en train de
mener au match
il faut absolument changer les
ouvertures alors on ne sait pas grave
indique en tout cas ne change pas une
méthode qui ne perd pas est ce que c'est
bien joué ça n'a pas changé
garry kasparov joue pareil tour a des
seins c'est exactement la même chose qui
va surprendre ses droits des uns où il
avait joué h3 d'abord non il a déjoué
tour à des uns pour anon
il a changé il a changé tout à fait
alpha a joué h2 h3 il avait joué le
nuage trois cliniques et rouge
un mythe et rouge parce qu'après h2 h3
et crâne qui avait joué b6 oui et la
torah d1 alors que l'adulte ou radeon
tout de suite donc peut-être b6 est pas
et peindre alors deux coups là parce que
on menace par ouahbi 7 alors garry
kasparov voilà l'amélioration bien les
casques sans fil ne perd pas de temps à
jouer h2 h3 h2 h3 kelkoo qu'ils allaient
jouer à dire une fois que nous allons
pointer ici
alors il ne perd pas de temps à jouer un
coup de pions inutile ils ne laissent en
h2 et ils préfèrent tout de suite mettre
sa tour en d1 non utilisées et loi alors
là c'est kasparov qui viennent changer
cratique a répété la même ouverture et
tu disais que par rapport au match que
kasparov avait joué contre allende
il n'est pas forcément intéressant de
répéter la même ouverture quand on mène
aux points est donc là cramique aurait
fait une erreur psychologique de répéter
la position c'est à dire que hollande
avait répété encore les avait continué
ses dires quand il avait gagné la 9e
partie du match ils monnaient d'un fond
et il avait continué à jour là mais
ouverture sur côté sportif avait sorti
de nouveauté fracassante à b6 quand même
mais il s'y sent même et on marque ce
cicas par juhasz 3 maintenant ça fait
que transposer tout à fait mais non il
ya hélas hélas il change de plan il joue
non non ils jouent le même plan mais
sans âge 3 ils jouent le même plan mais
ça h30 fin il gagne un temps qu'elle
sort gagnante en gagne un temps fait
milieu d'eux alors qu'est ce que ça veut
dire
qu'est ce qui vous plaît veillez à 4
manic-2 part of qu'est-ce qui lé jury de
kram nick la dernière fois difficile de
se
grief 4 je sais pas difficile à dire à
la casse par est ce que quelqu'un peut
jouer là même le même plan avec aleph 3
e 1 pour jouer f4 menacé g4 et f5
c'est possible c'est possible tout à
fait ça doit entrer dans les projets de
garry kasparov dans cette position donc
il faut revoir
évidemment vous pouvez revoir mais
d'ailleurs vous pouvez le faire en
direct puisque vous pouvez revoir le
différé de du résumé de dimanche à lille
le fameux résumé dès dimanche
tout à fait en cliquant dans les
archives en cliquant dans les archives
vidéo et donc vous pouvez revoir
l'analyse qu'on avait fait de cette
partie et vous pouvez le voir en anglais
par exemple avec le résumé en anglais en
cliquant sur le drapeau anglais
vous avez un bouton archives vidéo
évidemment qui vous permet de voir les
précédents résumé si vous voulez revoir
l'analyse de la partie de dimanche
dernier qui va ressembler beaucoup à
celle ci donc c'est les mêmes idées les
mêmes plans simplement une petite
différence kasparov a joué tout de suite
tours a des seins au lieu de jouer h2 h3
donc hyper pas de pions de temps pardon
un joint son pion ils n'ont pas le maire
ce donc
c'est ce qui pose ou alors un problème à
kramnik faisons une analyse de cette
position quand même ça me paraît
important de bien comprendre quand même
je ne sais si ces cinq là tranquille
comme qui joue les mêmes contre amical
joué c6 c5 on regarde on n'a pas peur
ce coup c6 c5 ça ressemble quand même
énormément à la première partie de ce
match amical air très calme et des
salaires en fait 38 cramé cul du web on
me il se lève et kramnik soldes ça tu
crois que j'avais pas vu ça prenez
s'élève au total à parapher surpris
kasparov
il se dit évidemment que fait crac
kasparov qui regarde qui regardent
kramnik s'éloigner avec un air voilà il
a des problèmes kasparov non mais là
kasparov rigole mais quel prof fait
comprendre à tout le monde qu'il a bien
entendu analyse et c6 c5 et qu'il ne
comprend pas du tout l'attitude de
chroniques qui est de se lever
alors qu'évidemment
mais c'est très bien les deux joueurs
savent que kasparov connaît et que
cramique connaît donc kasparov montre
sans doute à vladimir kramnik pas
recette
il ya deux meurtrières cet oeil à digne
d'un grand acteur américain exactement
il n'aya de 10 d'un grand acteur
américain tout à fait donc kasparov en
pleine réflexion sur ce plan elle peut
être qu'on peut voir gary kasparov de
près puisqu'il a une pause intéressante
je ne sais pas si le plan croisé est
intéressant ce n'est pas sûr
alors on va on va pendant que kasparov
is it en grance réflexion alors on va
passer exactement à l'échiquier ici de
démonstration pour expliquer loi encore
une fois l'idée de cette ouverture
les blancs donc ont échangé leurs fous
de cases blanches donc ils ont perdu le
contrôle un petit peu ténu des cases
blanches en échange de quoi ils ont donc
doublé les pions inverse donc on peut
montrer ses pions doublé donc ses pions
c'est cet essai 5 ici qui sont doublés
en échange de quoi donc
les blancs ont quatre pions du côté roy
qui sont les pions e5 f2 g2 et h2 contre
trois pions du côté noir f sept g7 et h6
ce qui donne une majorité de pions de ce
côté là pour les blancs donc le plan des
blancs est simple il faut avancer les
pions de ce côté-ci pour créer un
déséquilibre alors à mon avis la
compréhension cram unique et très fondée
dans cette position ce que pense
cramique tout simplement
c'est l'unique plan des blancs c'est
bien entendu d'essayer d'avancer cette
majorité c'est à dire de jouer f2f 4 et
j'ai dejé 4 suivi de f4 f5
ça c'est le seul plan mais ce que se dit
kramix et que évidemment dès qu'on
avance l'option j'ai deux options là dès
qu'il n'est qu'il est avancé eh bien ça
affaiblit toutes les cases blanches
d'autant plus que kasparov n'a plus de
force que ce blanche donc le fou décès
deviendra ans et 6 avec une diagonale
magique qui entrera complètement dans
quand blanc donc effectivement voilà
l'idée de vladimir wernick
positionnement sa position est solide et
fonder ses terres que si les blancs
jouent le seul plan qu'ils ont à leur
disposition ils vont faire des
affaiblissements ils vont donc prendre
des risques et c'est là que la partie
devient chaude
c'est là que la partie de ces chaudes
alors il faudra kasparov en gros ici en
train de réfléchir très tendu voilà très
jolie plein on l'a par notre réalisateur
vedette notre réalisateur étoiles ganic
il ya nique sur motivés pour cette
partie alors gary kasparov en pleine
réflexion
et oui incroyable il semblerait que une
fois de plus c'est kramis qui prennent
l'initiative dans l'ouverture c'est
quand même surprenant ça c'est quand
même incroyable alors disons mais c'est
très important cette partie pour le
match puisque kasparov évidemment s'il
n'avait pas rejoué la même ouverture
déclarant forfait entre guillemets oui
ça veut dire admet qu'il est dominé par
kramnik il est quand même championne du
monde numéro un mondial donc c'est aussi
une question d'honneur décidé de
démontrer qu'il peut trouver quelque
chose dans cette position
le problème c'est que kramnik à l'air
extrêmement bien préparé que cette
variante là il n'a pas joué par hasard
est ce qu en deux jours en faire un deux
jours en quatre jours puisque c'est
depuis dimanche
en quatre jours est-ce que kasparov a eu
le temps avec ses analystes avec ses
acolytes et ses ordinateurs et ses
ordinateurs mes chroniques aussi l'un
des ordinateurs de vérifier mais là
c'est pas une question ordinateur loi
non c'est pas dans cette position c'est
une question de plan à long terme plan à
long terme et les ordinateurs sont
capables de les trouver si on les fait
chercher quelques jours de suite
ils vont finir par trouver des choses
intéressantes peut-être peut-être
peut-être encore après qu'alain kasparov
tourner la tête
il n'a pas l'air satisfait par ce qui
est en train de se passer kasparov et
dépité dès ce début de partie
c'est proprement incroyable les dominer
kasparov
c'est encore lui qui réfléchit c'est
incroyable hein c'est fou il a choisi la
même ouverture et donc il avait une idée
il espérer quoique kramnik allait jouer
quoi
autre chose il avec eux
qu'est-ce qui pouvait espérer jeu commet
pas kasparov espérait peut-être que ce
parce qu'en fait dans la place ici s'ils
cassent maroc joue pas h2 h3 il ya
yannick gourdon krainik crâne nick n'a
pas peur fait n'a pas aussi n'ont plus
l'obligation de jouer le coup h 6 h 5
on va appeler l'idée il voit pourquoi je
dois je crois alors h2 h3 c'était bien
entendu ce coup là pour commencer à
pousser g2g capacité marine canadienne 5
et ainsi de suite parce que là l'idée de
kramnik cécile hénault blanc joue trop
vite ce plan un peu on peut tout de
suite mentionné le coût g2g kavala g2g 4
l'appartement
cette chronique a pas peur parce qu'il
joue cavalier cette e-menace h 6 h 5
et il menace haïti sachant que c'est à
dire que les blancs se sont tout
simplement affaibli leurs clients g4 est
venu là beaucoup trop tôt voilà alors à
6h à calais on va revoir faut quand même
expliqué loi pourquoi penses que coûte
embêtant le site hcm pas ce que l'on dit
supposons ici tout est hors défense ont
plongé 4 dans la vienne tout de suite en
prise par le fou le fou 17 attaques
plongée 4 voilà on va expliquer
supposons h2 h3 pour défendre voilà ce
que maintenant on défend comme ça ici
viendrait bien entendu le savez qu est
ce qu on va jouer à on va peut-être
regardez plutôt la partie donc ici
kasparov leixoes et de ces cas jouer ces
deux c4 entre les belles courses de la
partie de dimanche mais avec un temps de
moins pour les blancs c'est à dire que
les blancs pas perdu pour l'instant le
courage de l'e3 mais ce que je disais
sépulcre annick avait joué quasiment
après h2 h3 il avait joué à 6 h 5
oui oui donc en fait tant que
le coût à 6 à son utilité mais je crois
en tes fans qu'il y avait des variantes
dans lesquels on pouvait jouer après h3h
simple coup d'oeil au g4 quand même si
on prend g4 qui entrent en jeu les
quatre et la colonne h et est ouverte ce
qui posait des gros problèmes à kasparov
ouais poser de gros problèmes lourds ici
on peut très bien envisager de jauger
qu'un temps ouvrir la colonne h
c'est à dire qui aura pas la double
prise des pions h donc cet échange sur
la colonne et ça dans certaines
variantes garry kasparov peut sans doute
surprendre en jour a mis à dos noir il a
l'air à non mais là il a dû faire une
faute d' analyse incroyable oui là
dessus il a dû voir quelque chose qui
n'existait pas il a vu un fantôme tout
simplement c'est possible ça peut-être
il a l'air de ça il commence son
spectacle il est dépité il a l'air
dépité kasparov alors que cramique est
très très calme comme la cicrane iqpf
nuls 6 kramnik finir non pour retrouver
la même position finale et loire c'est
possible on peut encore autres la même
position finale il suffit que kasparov
juhasz 3 kramnik h5 et s'allier en à la
partie dimanche
on a la partie climatisées de kasparov
mais qu'est ce qu'il a fait il invite
dans les cordes il est dans les cordes
il a répété les coups il a en allant au
soleil il se verra sur son temps ce
souci à la normale un attaquant 10 de la
cram des jouets mais il a pas l'air
content kasparov non il n'a pas l'air
content du tout comme nick
qu'est ce qui lui arrive là qu'est ce
qui lui arrive à kasparov je pense
honnêtement qu'il ya une énorme faute
dans la préparation et que les seconds
en 2k sports vont passer un sale quart
d'heure après cette partie casse quand
vous allez les engueuler vallée
va leur dire que c'est n'importe quoi
qu'ils analysent n'importe quoi et
kasparov à mon avis ne va pas être
content du nom mais ce soir là il a dû
vérifier ses analyses et bien entendu il
est aussi responsable que c'est second
mais quand même quand même s'il ya une
faute dans cette analyse l'équipe dans
ce travail d'équipé
c'est dommage ça il ya une perte de
confiance qui va s'instaurer et ça c'est
très mauvais pour la suite du match bien
voyez parce que là que 6,6 kasparov ne
peut plus faire confiance à ses seconds
ans qui aurait trouver éventuellement
donc ici ça l'idée en fait il aurait
trouvé suite à la première partie une
amélioration pour kasparov or la
kasparov lui la tête qui fait et vu la
tranquillité de cramique en fait est en
train de se rendre compte semble-t-il
mais qu'il y aurait une gaffe que
celle-là thalys marche pas attention
parce que là si on peut revenir sur
l'échiquier de démonstration on va voir
quelque chose un détail très important
petit détail je crois alors nous allons
y revenir pendant que kramnik réfléchi
l'échiquier de démonstration ici je
pense qu'il ya un petit problème pour
vladimir kramnik alors
et non et non non on peut pas tout de
suite
nous sommes privés d'échiquier de
démonstration mais ce n'est que
momentanée donc nous avons un chronique
qui réfléchit voilà nous y sommes ici
cram nick je crois dans cette position
avait joué quelque chose comme cavalier
en hausse est donc on peut envisager ce
que cavani aux 7 qui parraine un découle
logiquement cette position ça c'est
possible de le cam newton sur quoique
askarov jouera à mon avis qu'il allait
en f4 et là ça change tout ça change
tout pourquoi pas se le cacher wallers
des scènes qu est-ce qu on ne peut plus
jouer kg 6 et néant ne peuvent plus
jouer leurs plans et donc et donc c'est
un problème puisque as part of a joué h3
et agi car c'est les noirs n'ont pas
vraiment cru dans cette version qu'a
sport peut simplement doublé sur la
colonne des caisses pense peut être peut
faire beaucoup de choses les pièces
noires ne sortent pas ici elles sont
embourbés elles sont enlisés à l'aide
dame
enfin alain le roy plus tôt et ça ça
pose un problème donc ici dans cette
blessure après 14 6 4
que peut jouer la dîmière crâne lisse
dommages aux cabrios est doit pas jouer
seul smic que matignon et coeuve à celle
qu il va jouer à 5 déjà mais à 5 à 4 à 5
à 4 mais ça on connaît ça on connaît ça
ne change pas grand chose
donc c'est une possibilité c'est une
année à 4 et la pourpre après je propose
par exemple kung fu ces six cas l'air
bien aussi alors fou c'est si ce n'est
pas parfait ce coût n'est pas parfait ce
coût n'est pas parfait puisque quentin
qui avait 10 ans des 5 c'est à dire
bon je ne sais pas exactement comment
bas il faut d'abord enlever enlever le
café f3 probablement peut-être temps des
trois ne marche pas très bien il faut
enlever de quatre ans il faut le mettre
au monde son cavalier angevin
éventuellement et ensuite l'autre
cavaliers passant des cinq par ces trois
ou quatre ans et trois ou quatre à noter
qu'un autre plan aussi c'est de mettre
les camions h saint louis mais ça
ressemble tout à fait trait pour trait à
la partie à un nom puisque le fou et ans
et si ce n'est pas sa case va se passer
par la case du cra mikhaylin et donne à
fond il a uni ont aussi assez vrai donc
ce n'est pas tout à fait pareil
en fait la question c'est vrai que co va
jouer travnik alors la question c'est
qu'il s'est il passé exactement
ces quatre dans cette partie on peut se
demander alors voilà nous allons mais
qu'est-ce qu'il avait joué chronique et
vient justement c'est ce que je suis en
train de regarder s'il n'y a pas
d'erreur ça s'est passé comme ça
à résister pas du tout pareil pas du
tout pareil
une petite différence donc kramnik
aurait joué dans le même ordre coup à
peu près il aurait joué à ce moment là
cavalier au 7 mai la cavalière 7 se
heurte un cavalier f4 qui a l'air de
boucher les noirs alors petit n'est
peut-être pas de coups chronique là tout
simplement
enfin notez enfin qu'un ordre de coups
un an mais elle voit la fosse et 6 voilà
trop fort tous ces six le coût qui n'est
pas parfait mais qui est jouée par
kramnik donc là ça y est ça des vies le
plan est plus le tout à fait le même
puisque la foux c6 sa pâleur de la jouer
tout de suite
olala il a joué tout de suit il a joué
qu'à manille f4 alors ça c'est
incroyable
alors là je veux tout de suite
incroyable ce coup cavalière 4
positionnement très très surprenant une
conception étonnante de garry kasparov
vrille parce que le feu le câble est roi
et emprises vraiment étonnante mais et
kasparov se lève alors la chronique va
réfléchir là c'est une certitude puisque
castrophe à jouer un coup atypique est
totalement ou pratiquement totalement
imprévisible il faut savoir exactement
quoi faire
nous allons passer sur l'échiquier de
démonstration puisque là nous avons une
position très intéressante ici garry
kasparov au 15e coup donne la
possibilité à vladimir kramnik de
cheveux fous pour un f3 qui affaiblira
qui cassera la structure d'options de
garry kasparov alors ailleurs l'aïe a
plus de majorité blanche regardant ce
coup qui avait des pressions prompt
lecavalier peut-être blanc en d5 qui va
être très beau dans les noirs ici vont
jouer bien entendu ces 7 6 7 6 et donc
ici c'est très clair lors quel est le
plan de garry kasparov dans cette
position que peut-il faire le tour des
trois tours à d un tour des trois tours
bien c'est un plan et la classe 17 à
l'air très affaibli donc les blancs vont
mettre une tour sur la case 17 c'est
peut-être ça l'idée oui on va montrer
ici tout simplement l'idée des blancs
donc alors nous allons envisager des
coûts
des coûts possibles pour les noirs des
coudes développer cette ou ces pannes
ont peut-être fois cette non peut-être
fawcett pour jouer tour hd vite
peut-être fou poussette pour jouer rober
cette étourderie tout simplement que
karine f5 et pas malin pour le noir et
le kode5 est excellent il est
indélogeable liliane délogeables
extrêmement il n'y a pas de pions blancs
qui peut l'attaquer il laisse aux cases
blanches donc le bleu foot pas
l'attaquer faut aussi de l'attaqué soit
par une tour on voit pas comment le seul
la seule autre pièce et le cavalier
blanc oui mais ce n'est pas un problème
puisque le fou en fait peut revenir sur
la case h4 ici les noirs ont l'air
d'avoir tout lé toutes les clés en main
pour obtenir une position solide ou
améliorer là où peuvent jouer les
cavaliers en g3 aussi un c'était bien
qui rétablirait la structure des pions
blancs
je ne comprends pas cavalier deux cas
les g3 week-end les 2 kg 3 ms points sur
lequel j'ai trois évidemment on bougera
le cavalier de f5 enrage 4 par exemple à
toi et il y aura absolument aucun
problème alors revoyons la position
actuellement en train d'être joué
garrincha soir a besoin de jouer
cavalier f4 c'est la grosse surprise
c'est la première fois qu'on voit un
coup aussi atypique dans ce match pour
l'instant stéphane ouais c'est vrai ça
laisse au noir une peau s'il allait vite
et paraît simple mais est-ce que cravic
faux cramique dans le sapeur de fou oui
mais alors qu rami qui avait évidemment
dans cette question peut chercher mieux
peu cherché à faire plus fort que faut
prendre froid il peut commencer par le
fou aux 7 c'est une possibilité
également fawcett pour jouer et orages
des huit c'est ça pour jouer ou alors il
peut jouer au rabais sat hocine merabet
7 il ya tour 17 tout de suite non parce
que le fouet ses 6 contres à winnezeele
en aura 17 europe et 7 mai
effectivement mais après il ya qu'à
valider cinq pour les blancs le kayak
trois essais comme on dit et l'a
peut-être les blancs menace de pénétrer
vraiment fortement dans le corps noir
zimeray oui c'est possible
non effectivement qu'il ya des saints
qui a l'air d'être la menace de kasparov
je pense que kramou devrait prendre un
f3 à moins qu'ils ont évidemment un gros
problème qui nous échappe
mais pour l'instant je ne vois
absolument pas ce que ça peut être je ne
vois vraiment pas quel est le problème
pour vladimir kramnik dans cette
position a priori une fois de plus il a
réussi à s'en sortir facile dans cette
ouverture est à noter que c'est
peut-être la première fois que kasparov
joue un coup et qu'on pense qu'il est
moins bien en fin ou en tout cas qu'il
n'a pas joué un coup bon ouais c'est
vrai c'est la première fois que nous ne
sommes pas surpris par la force d'un
coup de kasparov secoue cavalière 4 à
l'air plutôt douteux évidemment se cache
derrière une conception que nous n'avons
pas vu qui nous échappe
mais en fait ouais je suis en train de
réfléchir la pénétration des tours
blanches sur la case 17 n'est pas très
grave puisque en fait les noirs peuvent
jouer fawcett comme les recalés f5 et
complètement safe
oui donc ils peuvent jouer les fous au
set et ensuite tu auras des 800 problème
tout à fait absolument aucun problème
en fait ça a pas l'air de gêner grand
chose alors je ne comprends pas je ne
comprends pas ce que kasparov la vue
c'est proprement surprenant donc fou
price trois rois 17 euros ab set partout
point f3 il faut 7 pour la 3ème fois aux
7 semble hausse des taux rabaissés tout
de suite à venir alors qu'ici nous avons
un plan de kram nick 1.2 cramique qui
est en train de qui s'avance un peu sur
sa table qui a l'air assez tranquille
alors que je devais aller
richier que tout se passe bien pour nos
internautes quelques instants je vais
vous laisser avec stéphane laborde
commentaire donc là l'a dit mercredi qu
en réflexion il n'a pas l'air trop trop
gêné il a pas l'air trop gêné dans cette
partie alors c'est important parce que
s'ils arrivent à faire le nul dans cette
partie voire même cigale non évidemment
aussi kasparov fait n'importe quoi mais
bon s'il arrive au moins faire nul dans
cette partie kramnik aura marqué un
point énorme puisque ça fera deux fois
caspar se casse les dents sur cette
ouverture
il va falloir que kasparov passe à autre
chose la prochaine fois et là il risque
de se heurter encore une fois une
préparation du g unit tu puisqu'il a
l'air d'être très bien préparés en tout
cas d'avoir mis hors jeu
la préparation de kasparov
voyez le russe en réflexion mais
tranquille autant il était nerveux en
début de partie on sentait bien qu'il
était un peu nerveux
autant maintenant il paraît coyette
comme on dit ici à londres le 3 y est
coyette vladimir il semblerait que tout
se passe bien pour nos internautes et
que donc tout fonctionne admirablement
donc la voyez que nous sommes alors
peut-être un point autant on peut faire
un petit peu autant on rappelle que le
temps est toujours très important les
joueurs ont deux heures chacun pour
atteindre le 40e coup donc ils en sont
15e coup évidemment joué très vite
puisqu'ils ont répété la partie de
dimanche
donc pour l'instant au 15e coup kasparov
a utilisé un peu moins de 10 minutes et
chroniques
donc la chronique en réflexion depuis
maintenant quelques minutes
il faut que ils se comprennent en fait
il
évidemment ils calculent pas forcément
beaucoup de coups il essaie de
comprendre l'idée de gaspard enfin c'est
surtout ça le coup cavaliers f4 de
kasparov changent la conception de la
position puisque krainik peut prendre le
cavalier en f3 et donc obtenir une
position complètement différente
tout va jouer cramique
soit [ __ ] en f3 fou prendre cavaliers
en f3 pour casser la structure des pions
blancs soit un coût tranquille comme roy
bessette ou éventuellement fouet cette
voie on voit pas trop d'autres coups
pour cram nique
1 et fawcett est pas possible puisque
aussi si les noirs jouent fawcett
évidemment les blancs jouent tout de
suite le coût annoncé pendant sa marche
pas non plus long je fais une erreur de
conception je pensais que j'ai 2 et 4
mais le cavalier froisserait emprise
quoique non c'est pas possible on peut
pas donc la trame il peut jouer fou
prendre cavaliers f3 éventuellement
aussi fou au 7 ou encore roy en baisse
est l'idée droit baisse est simplement
de mettre en jeu la torah 8 qui va
pouvoir coulisser sur sa 8e ranger et
venir soit en des 8 soit en 8
éventuellement après fou aux 7es roi
bessette les deux tours sont connectés
et donc peuvent s'échanger
tranquillement sur la colonne des qui
est contrôlé actuellement par la
tour-blanche posté sur sa case d1 l'idée
donc des guides créer un contrepoids sur
cette colonne avec les tours alors
kramnik se pose la question parce que
[ __ ] en f3 salaire bien tout de suite
parce que ça casse évidemment la
structure des pions blancs mais ça
redonne la paire de fou ça redonne la
paire de fou et donc cramique ne peut
pas espérer que si la position s'ouvre
d'obtenir une compensation éventuels
avec ces fous alors qu'actuellement
c'est le cas les deux fous peuvent être
peut s'avérer devenir très fort si la
position prend un caractère ouvert il
suffit d'un pion échanger sur les droits
pour que tout de suite les fous et un
peu plus d'air et peuvent s'avérer très
puissant
il faut que kramnik moi je penche plutôt
pour un coup comme fou prend f3 tout
simplement qui a l'air qu'elle a bien
droit bessette aussi à l'air bien
puisque roy bessette on reste un peu
dans la structure de la position de
dimanche
c'est un petit peu semblable toujours en
train de réfléchir sur cette nouveauté
on peut dire que c'est là vraiment la
nouveauté de kasparov cavalière 4 oui
puisque c'est le coût qui change qui
peut changer le caractère de cette
position donc la cram dick est en
méditation et pour la première fois dans
ce match kasparov a pris d'initiative à
la pendule pris l'initiative dans
l'ouverture malgré ses limites de début
de partie c'est limite incessantes
il semblerait quand même que il ait pu
placer une idée intéressante dont pour
l'instant d'une comprenant absolument
pas le sens en fait stéphane non et
c'est peut-être tout simplement le sens
c'est peut-être tout simplement un ordre
de coups différents qui posent au
problème un problème en noir qui
dimanche avait trouvé des coûts et qu'il
a peut-être une possibilité de kumo
diminué oui ça resterait les
possibilités noir tout simplement france
alors on donne quand même une
une qui est vraiment intéressante qui
est vraiment oui car elle comprend
cavaliers ouais le coup que n'importe
quel joueur sur terre jour est
pratiquement à tempo contre n'importe
quel adversaire
mais ici effectivement ce ne sont pas
n'importe quel joueur et il ya sans
doute des idées qui échappent au commun
des des joueurs d'échecs fait il veut
garder sa part d'un fonds kramnik non
mais je pense que qu'il y ait des 5 eca
une menace sérieuse à mon avis ici
vladimir kramnik va jouer vous prend
cavaliers et surtout on prend fou hausse
est alors peut-être un échiquier de
démonstration pour pouvoir regarder ça
serait pas mal parce que là on est
vraiment au coeur du problème
il faut vraiment bien comprendre ce qui
se passe sur ce point m 3 alors voyons
échiquier de démonstration
donc
travnik toujours en train de réfléchir
c'est intéressant et on se demanderait
kasparov quand même en ce moment
stéphane puisque il faisait tout à
l'heure tout un cinéma comme quoi ça y
est j'ai encore raté quelque chose
ah ah quelle horreur j'aime être une
mauvaise préparation tout tout va mal et
l'a pourtant il joue son coût très vite
se lève et s'en va on ne le voit plus on
ne sait pas trop alors peut-être que
c'était une flotte de kasparov
parce qu'on peut évidemment je pense pas
que ce profane jamais avec ses mimiques
1 donc je pense que si las il a fait
cette grimace et qu'il y avait raison de
la faire et que quand on fait tout
simplement kramnik et serein seulement
il vérifie ses variantes tranquillement
il est peinard voilà et voilà on en
incroyable n'a pas pris il n'a pas pris
en bref trois mois les choses très très
surprenant il faudra lui poser cette
question à la conférence de presse
pourquoi n'at-il pas pris en f3 roi
bessette vraiment incroyable incroyable
dans le sens où ce n'est pas le coût
attendu
les deux joueurs sont partis ouais mais
là cramique bon alors il peut être tout
simplement et risqueriez encore une fois
on avait dit on avait vu dimanche que
tout
tous les pions toutes les c'est tout le
cannois remparts ont montrée peut-être
eloi d'ailleurs attention
kasparov va peut-être nous éclairer un
peu une tête loisirs c'est grâce à ça
grâce à sa tête très expressive son
visage très expressif il va peut-être
nous dire ce qu'il pense du coup de
crâne nique
c'est à voir pour l'instant il est en
pleine réflexion
non il n'a pas pu être surpris par ce
cours a baissé c'est impossible
complètement impossible donc qu'à sport
c'est ce qu'il va faire il va
probablement jouer cavalier des 5
c'est hautement probable
là ils ont réfléchi il est très
concentré d envoi ses pieds qui bouge
toujours ça c'est une constante plus ou
moins chez kasparov c'est quand il est
très concentré quand il réfléchit il
bouge les pieds et beaucoup de joueurs
d'échecs le font donc on ne sait pas
trop pourquoi peut-être pour évacuer un
peu de la nervosité de l'attention qu'il
ya dans cette troisième partie du match
a cédé là c'est pas non mais c'est pas
très agréable de rester vraiment
immobile est tout simplement si on reste
immobile pendant trop longtemps on
commence à avoir des fourmis dans les
jambes et ça devient pénible
donc il faut que nos sens et
psychanalyse il faut que le corps bouge
me plaît c'est une analyse intéressante
mais en tout cas la kasparov et très
concentré il est vraiment concentré donc
si on peut passer sur notre échiquier
pour regardez bien cette position non à
ondres l'instant pas on ne peut pas donc
la mairie kasparov qui réfléchit après
trame unique qui a l'air quand même
assez tranquille
qui a les records tranquille dans cette
position c'est clair ah ah super le
fameux coup d'une autre cravate le ne
travaille quelques retards nous fait
souvent ils jouent qu'à valider cinq
voilà c'est sans surprise il l'a joué il
a fait qu'il ait des 5 après avoir
desserré sa cravate ça veut dire qu'il
est une somme est en condition pour la
partie c'est ça je crois
ouais tranquille son fameux rituel il
enlève la montre il dessert sont
d'autres cravate là et kasparov et à
fond granic revient il est la chronique
truites que je chronique rami qui a
évidemment vu qu'à une et cinq sets-
c'est clair ça me lasserai un cavalier
desseigne de toute façon qu'ils étaient
simplement ça ne menaceraient mais ça
évite quand même qu'on puisse prendre en
f3 et elle fait bien la structure est ce
qu'on peut avoir notre échiquier de
démonstration peut-être
ça va venir on va pouvoir le récupérer
donc l'après cavalli des 5
voilà ça y est donc là on a notre
échiquier de démonstration donc après
cavaliers des cinq ici cette position
les derniers coups qui viennent de se
produire qui sont quand même très très
important alors à noter que par exemple
sur 6 les bleues noires jouer un coup
qui a l'air qui a l'air bon cavalier e
set
kamano 7 avec l'idée qu'elle est minée
2,7 stéphane je ne sais pas pour le
problème c'est qu'un camion 7 c'est bien
mais on ne peut pas prendre des cinq
puisque après puis on prend des cinq les
blancs renforceraient leur centre d'un
citron bio
donc ouais mais c'est un peu la même
idée que dimanche c'est en fait pour
parer fait pour empêcher le coup j'ai
dejé quatre premiers jouets qui avait
lieu cette c'est un aveu de faiblesse
puisque justement quel sport tu n'as pas
joué à trois mêlées kasparov menace g4
oui une manager 4 donc alors attention
puisque voilà la position actuelle sur
l'échiquier est la suivante
vladimir kramnik n'est pas surpris par
le dernier coup de casque europe il ya
donc déjà son idée sur ce qui va se
passer puisque maintenant que le fou est
plus un 17 0 4 et peut-être plus fort
puisque sur h 16 h 3 il est blanc
tranquille contrôle très bien à casiers
4 1 mais là tout de suite on comprend
très bien l'idée de kasparov
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il a poussé
cram michael sont fous sur la 4c 6 ouais
maintenant en lui plantant un cavalier
en d5 ils bouchent le fou ce fou n'est
plus efficace l'efficacité très limité
donc il a le champ libre pour pousser
ses pions et là je vous parie ray un
maximum que le prochain coup de kasparov
ses cavaliers ont suivi de f4 et julie
deux g4 et la cram mixera dans de beaux
draps
et parce qu'il veut pas jouer j4 tout de
suite on a fait peut-être un peu tôt
alors disons que pour l'instant c'est
dans un premier temps cet honneur de
jouer
donc c'est un problème il va falloir
trouver un bon coup pour krainik hch 5
mai à chacun qu'il y aura qu à ménager
sa rivale à leurs homologues avant
d'entrer ça tout de suite
on va bien et rien que le cavalier
tarifs 3 si on va jouer h5 pour prévenir
le coup j'ai dejé carte ses terres
contrôlées bien la 4g cap
il y a un problème c'est que le
cavalli blanc saute sur laquelle j'ai
cinq attaques le pion à vii et là ça
commence à faire
difficile pour chronique qui commence à
avoir des trous un peu partout qu'il ya
des problèmes ne serait ce que pour
défendre le pion à vii sa non ce n'est
pas possible qu est ce qu un trafic de
kasparov et réussi à poser des petits
problèmes un crâne ont alors là ce qu'il
faut bien dire dire qu'on va enlever les
flèches et ce qu'il faut bien dire dans
cette position c'est que chronique n'est
pas surpris donc à mon avis nous allons
être surpris par le coup de crâne unique
tant que tant qu'on ne l'aura pas vu
mais il doit y avoir une idée simple
pour les noirs qui permet de garder des
chances égales dans cette position je ne
vois pas là qu'elle s'est peut-être
cabello 7-6 8 kg 6 c'est possible hors
cac valeo scène voilà cavaliers cet art
mais justement je voulais alors qu'avec
cette l'a peut-être les noirs les blancs
peut faire cavalier prendre cavaliers
alors qu'elle les prend cavaliers
possibilité pour les bannières a priori
une possibilité qui n'est pas positionné
l'on sait forcément une vente tactique à
savoir intacte y voit là et après fou
prend peut-être aux sectes ou six alors
ça c'est une énorme faute stéphane sais
mais ça a l'air c'est une énorme faute
pourquoi et bien parce que je joue
simplement surprend pions et des fous
projet c'est ton idée était de jouer fou
prend g7 mais surtour génie tu mets les
noirs gabala une pièce donc c'est un
piège puisque après que le fonds prend
le pion à 6 et le puca électro epernay
qualif 3 perdu puisque l'option g2 est
cloué on va montrer c'est à dire car la
foudre en f3 de [ __ ] en f3 les blancs
ne peuvent pas reprendre le fou voilà
donc ça marche pas voilà tout ça donc ça
ne marche pas cette idée tactique est en
fait une succession de fautes
positionnelle puisque dans un premier
temps on joue camille prend cavaliers
qui ouvre la diagonale du fou
ouais et dans un deuxième temps après
fou prompt aux six pions prend aussi ce
fou prend g7
eh bien nous ouvrons la colonne pour la
tour et là ça commence à faire vraiment
beaucoup trop donc ce n'est pas possible
c'est une langue qui ne marche pas sûr
qu'ils aient des cinq les doigts peuvent
jouer kermadio 7 on enlève ses flèches
donc comme ils le souhaitent c'est
faisable mais ça un bouteille un peu les
pieds ce moment intime de cette salle
une idée aussi derrière la tête stéphane
c'est l'idée c'est de jouer le tour des
mythes et pourquoi pas tout de suite
tournait vite on peut jouer tout de
suite également tout à fait ça a l'air
d'y jouer autour des 8 tout de suite
mais oui normal en là on peut on peut
revenir dans l'opposition précédente et
envisager maintenant le coutour d'élite
ça effectivement interne sur tour des
huit tout de suite peut-être les blancs
chez pas battre les blancs ici vont
clairement doubler les tours sur la
pologne dont on attendait 3 et 3ds
apparaît sur tour des trois là on ne
sait pas trop ce que peuvent faire les
noirs puisque le point des 5 va être
très bien tu vas être sûr protégé c'est
les commentaires de nîmes zollitsch
il faut se protéger les points
importants donc si une fois qu'on aura
mis la deuxième tour en d1
le cahier des 5 sera défendu par trois
pièces il sera donc très très bien
protégés et ça c'est important
non ici à mon avis à mon avis dans cette
position dans cette situation cramique
va jouer qui avait lieu cette l'idée de
jouer pour des vides dont kasparov va
s'en prémunir
ange m'entourent des trois c'est à dire
qu'on commence à essayer de blinder la
classe des 5 et c'est tout à fait
logique et la g league devra trouver un
coup dans cette position et une pointe
tactique est avancé par l'ordinateur a
toujours en éveil
c'est cavaliers pros cavaliers suivi
d'une d'une enfilade harvey en enfilade
on va voir l'hôtel de l'enfilade et
prend des cinq très joli thème puis on
prend des cinq qui comprend des cinq
forcé et là alors a priori il faut de
positionnelle grave pour les noirs
puisque les blancs ont installé deux
pions centraux très fort on est ici il y
a bonus folie 5-5 attaque la tour et
l'autre tour d'un interrogateur bouge
c'est celle qui est derrière qui va
prendre donc ici point tactiques tour
des trois n'est pas possible après avec
evans est très joli piège donc nous y
revenons langue et nous considérons bien
entendu le coup plus logique tour des 2
es très exactement temps des deux qui a
les nerfs des avantages sans
l'inconvénient majeur de perdre tout de
suite une qualité va tout droit vers
davantage de protéger le cavaliere 3,7
mvan ça pouvait travail
terry est ici que peut faire chronique
et bien a priori pas facile puisque
kasparov
on le voit on voit clairement son idée
parce qu'il peut pas jouer à 5 à 4 déjà
ça peut pas sinon c'est peut-être moins
intéressant qu'un homme alors à cinq à
quatre ça ne sert plus à rien puisque le
fou on ne peut plus venir en c2 ne peut
plus rêver devenir enseignant ouais donc
c'est pas du tout indispensable
non je pense que ici il faut bien jeter
un oeil sur la position en cours et on
voit quelque chose de très clair qui
vient de me sauter aux yeux maintenant
après ces quelques analyses de variantes
kasparov a blindé complètement les
points des 5 et e5 qui sont les deux
avant-postes dans le conte noir
ils sont surprotégés on va des têtes il
va simplement tout jouer jouer tout en
oeuvre alors que ce parent non vas fort
et je pense qu'il va chercher maintenant
qu'il assure protéger son centre centre
n'est pas attaqué on va on va commenter
cette surprotection quand même le
camélidé 5 tout d'abord est défendu par
l'option c'est et par la tournée et par
la tournée c'est à dire qu'il est
défendu deux fois et attaquer une seule
donc il effectue un saut pions en eux
cinq est défendue par le four b2 d'un
four b2 et le cavaliere trois cavaliers
3,6 alors qu'il n'est pas du tout
attaquer donc il est encore plus c'est
qu'ils ont ici n'ira kasparov tient le
centre et ça ça peut poser un problème à
kramnik cependant je pense que le coup
de crâne nick va nous surprendre ici à
munich va jouer un coup que nous n'avons
pas prévu stéphane j'en suis
pratiquement percevez c'est possible
peut-être j'ai vite peut-être temps j'ai
vite et que c'est effectivement j'étais
en train de penser à ce compte il faut
dire que les blancs qui a tellement bien
le centre que les noirs sont obligés de
jouer sur le côté mais surtout j'ai vite
fait d'être h3 est très fort du coup je
croyais pas ce qu'ils veulent mais je
crois le costume
ou g4 montre tout simplement gk tout de
suite chez kg 4 et on peut jouer
cavalier h4 non ici ça a l'air très
chaud alors récapitulons quand même pour
ceux qui viennent de nous rejoindre
tout ce qui est en train de se passer
dans cette troisième partie il s'agit
d'un match garry kasparov champion du
numéro un mondial depuis 15 ans contre
son dauphin vladimir kramnik qui n'a que
25 ans et qui est numéro deux mondial
matches en 16 parties pour l'instant ses
deux challengers qui al avantage
puisqu'ils mènent un an et demi 1/2 et
ici les joueurs sont en train de répéter
la même ouverture que lors de la
première partie l'admirent krainik est
donc serein il avait fait nul avec la
pièce noire est ici kasparov a trouvé
une nouveauté pour améliorer et vladimir
kramnik est en train de réfléchir pour
voir ce qu'il peut faire contre cette
amélioration de garry kasparov
alors là on voit que tu as parfois l'air
effectivement d'avoir gagné le combat
l'ouverture aujourd'hui c'est que
vladimir kramnik à utiliser 35 minutes
de réflexion contre à peine 12 à
kasparov
oui oui ça c'est un élément révélateur
on va voir comment krainik se comporte
dans une pareille situation c'est à dire
dans la situation que c'est son
adversaire qui est maladroit kramnik à
répéter les coups alors ça c'est
psychologique c'est psychologique on ne
peut pas vraiment le comprendre
on verra après ce que les joueurs on
pense peut-être qu'ils nous diront de
toute façon ils en parleront après le
match voilà un très beau plan encore sur
kramnik lab la formule très important
d'envoyer ouais donc on vous rappelle on
vous rappelle on le rappellera chaque
fois parce que c'est très important si
vous découvrez les échecs aujourd'hui ou
si vous découvrez la retransmission d'un
match d'échecs si vous êtes passionné
par ce jeu on vient de voir la pendule
on vous rappelle que les joueurs ont
deux heures chacun de réflexion tant
qu'ils aient décret mentez quand c'est
aux joueurs de jouer
il ya deux pendule donc et
ces deux heures de réflexion sont
valables jusqu'au 40e coup c'est à dire
qu'il faut atteindre le 40e coup en
moins de deux heures si on dépasse ce
temps de réflexion avant le 40e coup ci
par exemple 35e tout cas chroniques des
passes et des heures de réflexion
eh bien il perd la partie et au bout de
40 coups une heure de temps
supplémentaire est ajouté aux joueurs
pour jouer les vingt coups ou ludiques
ou suivant puisque les vins coutume les
vingt coups suivants pour jouer les
vingt coups suivants et ensuite au bout
de ces d'un coup suivant ils ont chacun
une demi heure qui sont rajoutées à leur
temps pour terminer la partie charnue la
partie c'est ce qu'on appelle la cadence
classique s'est laissée chez classique
les échecs long il ya aussi le jeu en
semi rapide mais ici ce n'est pas notre
notre sujet puisque communément le
champion du monde est celui qui gagne
les parties longues et non pas les
parties rapides
voilà on vous rappelle pas quand même
que vous pouvez voir dans les différer
de diagonale les tournois de parties
rapides que nous avons suivi cette année
par exemple le grand prix de bordeaux où
le grand prix du sénat on peut citer
encore le match de bastia entretiennent
bacrot et judit polgar tous ces matchs
sont disponibles dans la base de données
de diagonale l'émission sur les échecs
de canal web et donc vous pouvez les
regarder les re regarder quand vous le
souhaitez à munich en pleine réflexion
il a l'air un petit peu non en fait il a
l'air de rien ils crament nick ne laisse
transparaître aucune émotion qu'il soit
gagnant ou perdant il arbore toujours le
même visage énigmatique on ne sait pas
du tout ce que pense la dynamique
actuellement peut-être qu'il a vu un
chemin pour faire nul facilement
peut-être qu'il est en train d'en
chercher un peut-être qu'ils doutent
qu'ils pensent qu'il est peut-être déjà
très mal on ne peut rien lire sur ce
visage impassible
c'est vraiment un très bon joueur de
poker
et là ils seront étendus à la fois c'est
très difficile à décrire on ne peut
absolument rien dire il faut comprendre
encore une fois l'enjeu de cette partie
s'est pas uniquement évidemment le point
de gagné ou pas c'est le fait que
l'ouverture choisi par kramnik peut
tenir la route ou pas et après donc
réflexion de classe par an fait de son
équipe
kasparov a sorti aujourd'hui nouveauté
par rapport à la partie dimanche dernier
ils ont joué à peu près les mêmes
premier coup caspar en faire dévier de
la partie de dimanche dernier et donc à
essayer de est en train d'essayer de
démontrer que il a d'autres plans qui
sont très dangereux dans cette ouverture
or la chronique concentré très concentré
la tête penchée en avant
je ne sais pas je ne sais vraiment je ne
peux pas dire ce joueur c'est impossible
donc je crois qu'il nous reste plus qu'à
faire un bilan position une fois de plus
voilà la position actuelle le centre de
gary kasparov surprotéger et vladimir
kramnik on peut revenir sur les deux
coups précédents c'était très important
dans cette position garry kasparov vient
de jouer kalyev 4 g nick a choisi de ne
pas prendre en f3 on se demande encore
pourquoi on ne le sait pas un stéphane
finalement pourquoi chronique n'a pas
pris en f3 pour affaiblir les structures
de kasparov
on sait simplement qu'il a joués roi
bessette permettant à casa sports de
jouer qui est des cinq et de tenir ainsi
toutes les cases centrale alors c'est
vraiment surprenant ce qui est en train
de se passer dans cette partie c'est
c'est du très haut niveau en tout cas du
niveau qu'on ne peut pas expliquer
actuellement peut-être que les prochains
pour nous éclairer un petit peu plus ce
qui arrive souvent
oui mais là on voit que j'ai
l'impression que vladimir s'abîme dans
des réflexions
on voit qu'il est
plongée dans la réflexion l'essai de
bien s'imprégner de la position et
d'essayer de trouver le plan à faut
rappeler aussi que cramique est un des
joueurs au monde qui perd le moins deux
parties oui puisqu'il était sur une
série de 80 partis sans défaite avant de
perdre contre michael adams autant à
dortmund en juillet c'est proprement
incroyable même garry kasparov n'a
jamais réalisé un tel exploit
et oui donc c'est l'un des joueurs qui
est le plus dur à battre on peut
rappeler dans l'histoire du jeu d'échecs
par exemple notre joueur qui avait cette
réputation c'était le champion du monde
cubain jose raul capablanca très très
grand champion et qui perdait très très
peu de parties je crois que capablanca a
dû être champion du monde pendant très
très longtemps enfin depuis la date où
il a été champion du monde il n'avait
perdu qu'une dizaine de partis ce qui
est tout à fait exceptionnel ouais
surplus de peut-être deux ou trois sans
jouer c'est totalement incroyable
capable en question est effectivement
entré dans la légende suite cette série
cette réputation de joueur ultra solide
et c'est peut-être le destin qui attend
vladimir kramnik par exemple si dans ce
match et ne permet aucune partie ce
serait tout à fait incroyable ce serait
du jamais vu puisqu'il n'y a jamais eu
un match où le champion du monde n'a pas
perdu deux parties ça n'est jamais
arrivé
donc ici cramique pour l'instant après
deux parties en tout cas tient la corde
tient la corde sur la corde et peut-être
le nouveau le futur champion du monde
voilà un homme qui détrônera kasparov on
voit bien avec la pendule ici le
problème de kramnik aujourd'hui c'est
que il prend beaucoup de temps début on
rappelle que aussi kasparov a perdu la
seconde c'est probablement parce qu'ils
étaient mal autant c'est une des raisons
mais effectivement il était sous
pression constamment la pendule n'aidant
pas ici cramique semble avoir du mal à
trouver un coup vraiment
c'est quand même incroyable puisqu'il a
joué très rapidement roy 17le son
dernier coup il fait jouer très vite et
sur la réponse évidente de kasparov ça
plonge l'admirent kramnik dans une
réflexion complètement inattendu en fait
ouais il semblerait que kasparov et
pointer du doigt les faiblesses de cette
position cette ouverture c'est le manque
d' espaces des pièces noires et leurs
problèmes à se développer dans la grosse
question c'est est-ce que cramique dont
elle a pu prendre la f3 la deuxième
question c'est est ce que craint munich
va trouver une solution maintenant
mais attention il faut aussi que ça
suffit pas de dire bon les noirs sont
pas développés il faut que kasparov
trouve un point attaques tant que
peut-être qu rami qui peut jouer des
coups je sais pas ils jouent tour à 8
puis après il y au tour tour 6 tours 8
tours aux 6 et puis voilà non mais le
plan de casse pas dans cette position le
connaît alors on va leur détailler une
fois de plus on va revoir la position
parce que quel est le plan que concret
que kasparov peut mettre en place dans
cette partie pour déstabiliser la
position noir c'est l'impression que les
noirs pour l'instant contrôle bien tous
leurs points peut-être que la case f7
qui est un peu faible mais n'ont même
pas le moment l'attaqué
le plan de kasparov est très simple
considérant ce que tu as dit stéphane
latour viendrait sur la case 1,8
c'est une possibilité pour 8 c'est tout
à fait possible
là le plan de kasparov s'est bien
entendu de bouger ce cavalier ou alors
de jouer j'ai quatre avant ce qui est
une autre possibilité par exemple
considérons ici la possibilité g2g 4 le
cavalier viendrait sur la case hausse
est un cas et maintenant on pourrait
peut-être jouer un coup comme cavalier
mais là on joue à 6 h 5 probablement et
sur h5 simplement le coup h2 h3 pourquoi
pas et là un petit problème c'est qu'on
fait éventuellement pions projet car son
projet 4 donc angers 4 et la tourache
quatre tours h4 alors il y à une
invitation mentionné par l'ordinateur
je pense qu'on peut
peut-être avant de regarder tous âges
car ici l'ordinateur après que
l'histoire des huit qui gagne l'option
des cinq en force
oui parce que la tour des uns et la
tournée 1 s'est retrouvé cloué à
l'effacer le cahier des scènes qui est
cloué et la tour d un effectivement
n'est pas défendu et voilà tout
simplement c'est bien d'avoir un petit
ordinateur pour vérifier ça c'est
important
donc j'ai quatre effectivement n'est pas
à l'ordre du jour surtout robeet garry
kasparov va préparer tout ça alors
peut-être cavaliers joueurs
éventuellement h 2 h 30
mais là on retrouve la partie presque ah
non non on ne retrouve plus du tout la
partie on ne retournera jamais la partie
parce que le fouet le coup est parti sur
une case mauvaise oui pour venir oui ou
non il en est de relativement bien il
aura du mal à revenir nancy pour venir
parce qu'il peut craindre que je crois
c'est huit mois ils n'ont mairie
ressouder 7 stéphane il ne faut pas non
plus perdre beaucoup trop de temps alors
on va considérer ce court assez vite
qui donc là on va le dire et quand même
anti positionne n'avait déjà d'un an
déjà kramnik la l'entourage 3d jacques
rémy à nice joue pas le sien qui peut
pas alors on l'a remis moi c'est 8
on va quand même se demander ce qui se
passe sur le coup j'ai 4 ans parce que
là ça commence peut-être à être à
l'ordre du jour donc la cabrio sept
cavaliers 7 est maintenant cavalier e 1
est possible qu'ils aient des de perdre
un pion cali hkpq il y aurait eu cinq
c'est pas évident en fait c'est très
difficile pour les blancs de mettre en
place cette attaque deux pions dans des
bonnes conditions et puis même si les
purs avance encore une fois bon
faux pas c'est quoi ça suffit pas
d'annoncer non alors peut-être que au
lieu 2 h 3 garry kasparov dans cette
position peut envisager cavalier e 1
pourquoi pas mais là cavalier a eu un
donc là donc lamela kramnik
effectivement en tout cas lieu un jour
par exemple coup comme cavalier au cette
commune de 7 on se rappelle quand même
la dernière fois au kram nique sur
cabello avait joué h5
oui mais là c'est plus pareil parce que
s'ils jouent à 100 à oui on peut jouer
cinq mois je sens qu'ici
ah oui non sauf que relief trois
peut-être sur le 5 km
oui oui c'est ça la embêtant c'est
possible c'est possible mais ici donc tu
peux propositions possibles pour les
noirs c'était cavaliers au set mais je
ne pense pas que ce soit le meilleur
peut-être qu'à sport offre aux
maîtresses et pièces en jeu il peut
jouer qu'à laisser deux dans cette
position avec l'idée de revenir en 23
d'où il contrôlera les cases
ouais mais laraque et g4 comme important
pour l'avancée futur de son duo de pions
et là ils auraient une position en or
j'ai l'impression qu'à raqqa sport pour
obtenir une vraiment une très belle
position
donc il faut que kramnik soit très
précis alors surtout robin proposition
qu'avait lieu la position actuelle la
voilà une fois de plus craints munich
est en train de réfléchir depuis ça fait
combien temps de crise la chine bientôt
une de mes reins oui ça peut l'être luan
d'une demi-heure et là il en est à trois
quarts d'heure de réflexion cramique ça
y est c'est lui aujourd'hui qui est sous
la pression de kasparov s'agit pour la
première fois du match
on va jouer il valait à mach oui il va
jamais la cram il va jouer à lille quand
même il n'a pas l'air il a pas l'air
content il n'a pas l'air content comme
nick wey il a pas l'air sûr de lui
les embêter il était sur le point de
jouer d'être une erreur d'avoir répété
cette partie il aurait peut-être dû
essayer de varier un peu c'est facile à
dire évidemment pas jouer il va jouer il
vérifie qu est-ce qui fait et vérifie il
a décidé son coût y voilà comme ça oui
oui tout à fait la chronique a choisi
son coup il est en train de juste faire
les comment dire comme on pourrait dire
comme quand un avion va décoller on a
les dernières vérifications d usage
vérifiez que le moteur tourne par
exemple vérifier que le tableau de bord
fonctionne c'est les dernières petite
vérification en fait cramique vérifie
qu'il n'est pas de grosse gaffe dans ses
calculs et il joue à cavalier aux sept
g7
paris 2 sept ça a pas l'air très bon oui
mais alors là sur cavale de ben oublions
pas qu il ya le passage en force autour
des 8 oui alors sur calvillo 7
rappelons le nous l'avions prévu nous
avions envisagé comme un test parfait
est arrivé à temps il va peut-être jouer
tout de suite alors kasparov
voilà donc hélios est ce ça ne l'a pas
surpris donc nous nous avions prévu sur
ce coup le coutour d2 pour garry
kasparov
ouais c'est une prédiction diagonale on
va voir si kasparov et donc pas tour des
trois grosses erreurs intense voilà
alors là il ya deux pièges effectivement
il ya ke ha détroit qu'il faut éviter
qu'un baigneur et en d3 sont deux fautes
en temps de kasparov réfléchit on va
peut-être vous montrer les possibilités
possible voilà les deux fautes à ne pas
faire voilà la première ses cavaliers
câble et une faute puisqu'il ya autour
des 8 pour les noirs et on voit que le
cavalier des 5 es foutu tour des huit
tours de 8 c'est possible mais il n'y
aurait qu'un essai 3 il y a plus fort il
y as cavaliers préemption des cinq qui
est avoir mentionné par l'ordinateur
puis en cas d'un des cinq g5 comprend
des scènes et fougue et sa fougue et
cinq attaques la tour et attaque la tour
afin qu'ils étaient trois et forcé et a
maintenant 11 autour des mines est un
tour des huit qui gagnent un pion qui
gagne un pion avec donc un net avantage
pour les noirs ça c'est une première
erreur à ne pas faire
et deuxième erreur deuxième erreur c'est
le coutour détroit qui cette fois ci est
très simple refus d'être simplement oui
il y à cavaler point cavaliers quelle
époque cavaliers si on prend en compte
si on prend et 5 b 5e foulées scène qui
attaquent les deux tours voilà une des
deux va devoir se donner contre le fou
si ce qui est une très mauvaise affaire
donc la fameuse enfilade alors revenons
à la position dans laquelle kasparov
réfléchi nous avions préconisé le bouton
d2 qui paraît le plus logique
pourquoi ces de la surprotection
stéphane surprotection on va jouer tous
rêvent d un homme probablement tôt f d
un nul alors à deux tours comme ça
toutes les tours joue et le point des
cinq soit défendu trois fois
quoique c'est pas tout à fait dans le
plan kasparov et qu'il faut qui pousse
ses pions parce que là il peut pas
pénétrer finalement sur cette colonne
mais le plan d'un point de vue
philosophique on va dire d'abord il faut
stabiliser la position et ensuite
commencé la taxe sur l'aisne comme on
dit attac soins quand on tient le centre
après on a les mains libres pour aller
sur les ailes ici kasparov surprotège
son centre et ensuite il envisagera une
attaque soit à gauche ou à droite et
vraisemblablement à droite de
l'échiquier puisque c'est là qu'il a
capturés contre trois des quatre voies
mais il ne saurait cramique dans le sens
du style
kasparov aussi qu'est ce qu'on fait là
tranquille aussi
bah disons qu'ils risquent pas perdre
kasparov jusque pas perdre cette partie
non mes enfants quand ces deux joueurs
d'un tel d'un tel niveau des pertes avec
les noirs se comptent sur les doigts
d'une main
des pertes acquerra cv qui prennent un
risque inconsidéré
là c'est peut-être kasparov maintenant
qui va plonger dans un abîme de
réflexion
à
il a l'air de savoir propose qui veut
jouer by a pas l'air si sûr de lui ouf
poule à
elle calcule
un kasparov look est actuellement et en
grand
ans de réflexion
ah il tapote avec les mains il n'a pas
l'air moi je sais pas il n'y a pas l'air
complètement satisfait non c'est de se
dire mais bon c'est ça m'ennuie cette
opposition là lorsque je suis en train
de se dire ça là il est en train de se
je pense qu'il est à fond là kasparov là
il a vraiment envie de gagner cette
partie
enfin remarqué là il boude un peu là où
la houlala
et voilà la fameuse montre de kasparov
ici qui est posé sur la table il faut
rappeler que kasparov a l'habitude donc
de poser sa montre comme ça juste avant
la partie ça lui permet probablement
aussi de vérifier que le temps de la
pendule est en phase avec celui de sa
montre et donc de signaler à l'arbitré
un éventuel déphasage comme il l'avait
fait hier comme il a dû le faire hier il
avait peut-être remarqué que le le temps
ne se dégrade un décret n'était pas tout
à fait à la lure voulu il n'ya vraiment
vont vraiment très très concentré la vie
dans pendule milan pendule cram nick a
réfléchi 45 minutes
kasparov a réfléchi 17 minutes donc pour
l'instant
kasparov a pris l'initiative dans
l'ouverture ils allaient blanc il est un
peu mieux et il est mieux à la pendule
bref il a beaucoup davantage qui
combiner les uns avec les autres peuvent
aboutir à une victoire à aaa en salle
alors là ça sinon ça c'est ça c'est ça
c'est la première fois que je vois
kasparov de cette allure là il sait ce
qu'il est en train de se dire là à quoi
pensent kasparov
elle ne bouge plus la laine on ne bouge
plus oh là là il est vraiment il est
vraiment incroyable une position qu'on
ne lui connaissait pas
elle craint microbien kramnik revient à
la table à wade devant un air pareil
granak revient devant une telle question
ne branche pas qu'elles peuvent s'est
remis dans une allure normale quand même
grammy qui l'a fait revenir à la normale
well as l'air tranquille chronique là on
sait pas on dirait que les deux joueurs
un peu seront 100 mdsy quoi savent pas
trop quoi penser de ce coût de cette
position est ce que cramique aurait
trouvé une réfutation
de l'espagnol il va bien le noise ferait
elle lui là tu as tous les coups bas il
n'y a pas que la berlinoise ya également
la petrov qui en ce moment sont les
ouvertures neutralisante sur leucate
rappelons quand même
l'inconvénient de ces ouvertures dit
annulant tu sais qu'elle n'offre
absolument aucune chance de gain ça
c'est un important ouais c'est dommage
c'est à dire que là c'est alors que les
blancs peuvent essayer de gagner mais
risque pas perdre mais de l'autre côté
bomber et si kramnik maintenant il a un
peu en avance il fait 14 nuls et il est
champion du monde
tour à tour un kasparov dans une logique
de surprotection tous eu un doux rêveur
surprenant cependant ce coup j'ai
l'impression que ça permet quelque chose
de très simple pour vladimir kramnik ça
permettrait le coup tout à 8 ans des
huit que nous allons considérer dès
maintenant sur l'échiquier démonstrative
mais quand on aura vu quel sport va dire
quel intérêt tout même des vies et bien
c'est que sa chasse que caïds et 5 ça
attaque le cabinet safège échange de
pièces avait lui-même et après la casse
d'éviter faible il va falloir jouer roi
c'est 8
non mais ça c'est non mais attention
stéphane les noirs n'ont pas beaucoup d
espace ils doivent quand même chercher
des échanges de pièces dans cette
position est-ce que c'est sûr à sa
paresse apparition à je crois avoir vu
peut-être la possibilité une possibilité
intéressante sur tour débute alors là je
pense qu'on va on va y venir
oui allons-y tour des huit lourde et si
oui oui tour des huit l'avantagent d'où
ce coup évidemment le cas des cinq est
attaqué trois fois par le fou par le
cavalier way et par la tour ouais et ici
on peut supposer que kasparov pourrait
jouer cavalier pro cavaliers ou savent
pas leur a lancé une idée
c'est une idée donc ce n'est pas carla
lioret tour prend tour à tour prend tour
à tour pro tour
et là faut prendre cavaliers fou prend
cavaliers et il semblerait que les noirs
éclate de rire tous à gauche
donc en fait ce n'est pas une option
pour garry kasparov est ce que là il n'y
a pas de problème pour les noirs à
mamers et même avantageux pour les noirs
et loi c'est probablement un léger
avantage pour un arbre est tout à fait
tout à fait si les noirs seraient mieux
à ce que la attention et à saint-cast
menaces à 4 déjà falloir jouer à quatre
le fou sait s'il va venir à 24 avec une
invasion des cases blanches très
dangereuse
non ici clairement ce n'est pas sa
colère ça valait donc que se passe-t-il
sur tours débit voilà il faut que
kasparov joue cavalier ou 3 oui mais
alors enlevé ce cavalier c'est quand
même une sorte de capitulation nom
stéphane on ouais ouais je sais pas eh
bien oui je sais pas non ici il n'ya
peut-être quand même quelque chose
elle avait 14 villas subtil on a vu
quelque chose il ya peut-être aussi ce
qui va jouer je voudrais il ya 2,6 dans
l'air et de 6 en l'air là qu'est ce qui
se passe sur alors regardons tout de
suite le couple aux states is a avec
l'idée l'idée simple c'est que le foot
b2 boom tape sur g7 dire que la menace
ses cavaliers price est suivi de fou
prend g7 éventuellement bah oui ou non
il ya toujours ce tour g 8 g alors 6
donc très logiquement on ne peut pas
tolérer un pion comme ça il faut le
prendre
donc on peut prendre syrte des cercles
qui on prend aussi ce très logique et là
que se passerait-il
que se passerait-il tour prend aussi ce
taux peut ainsi accueillir quatre
également qui est à prendre en ligne de
compte et l'ordinateur qui propose une
variante à priori intéressante le coup
cavaliers f3 en jeu 5
et là ça devient extrêmement chaud
stéphane puisque le cavalier venir faire
une fourchette sur la case à vii une
fourchette un 8/10 également attaque
double il attaquera les deux tours ouais
et gagnera donc du matériel ici s'avère
très chaud pour cramique on voit si on
regarde cette position tranquillement
d'une défense on voit que kasparov à des
pièces placées d'une façon superbe de
cavaliers au centre soutenu par deux
tours le four b2 qui a une superbe
action ici ça commence à faire beaucoup
d'ailleurs on le voit c'est aurait pu le
jouer c'est un jouet pour eux
donc s'il a joué thorens et qui a choisi
non mais c'est qu'il date encore des
mythes
il attendra rien à perdre il attend que
la tour soit en des mythes pour pouvoir
placer cette fameuse fourchette ouais
mais ça a pas l'air dangereux puisque
affoué 8 c'est ça dans cette position x
ouais bah ça l'air d'être le seul coup
qui par la fourchette brillant sa fin au
mythe et ça a l'air solide
de l'autre côté solide mais difficile
non à près de 4,4
cette position ne fait pas envie on ne
fait pas envie stéphane on n'a pas envie
de jouer ça quand même
contre une bête d'initiatives comme
garry kasparov
voilà mais si ça tient il aime tourner
plus hoyé enfin avec la paire de sushis
en plus il faut il faut relativiser de
plus en plus avec le père de huawei mis
à part de foule de plus en plus ça finit
par faire beaucoup
c'est possible non c'est possible ici le
bon coup semblerait tour des six c'est
un massacre a dit qu'il est si chronique
est-ce que kramnik est un assez bon
défenseur pour jouer ce type de position
à bas bien entendu une chronique est un
des meilleurs défenseurs du mouvement
mais il a pris la fuit il a bien fait
tout reprend mme bessette
oui je tombe mardi les taux prendre 17
sachant qu'il allait normalement
souffrir devant l'initiative de kasparov
il est fait tout reprendre 17 il a pris
le pion de plus et il a réussi à dominer
la partie alors peut-être là il va il va
rentrer dans cette variante aillent là
l'erreur hier il a l'air il allait
inviter regarde aussi l idée dit si on
peut voir la chronique
granic qui regardent au ciel là c'est un
moment important du match il presque une
heure de réflexion pour chronique il
reste neuf minutes pour passer leurs de
réflexion rappelons qui doit terminer
ses quarante premiers coups dans le
temps qui reste donc il reste une heure
neuf pour jouer ces quarante premiers
cours oui là ils envisagent les
complications
c'est clair mais ils ont déjà joué 17
coup les joueurs comme ils ont joué vite
d'ouverture donc en fait kramnik est
dans les temps si le h3 coup pour
athènes le 20e et s'il a mis une heure
pour jouer un coup il peut très bien
mettre une heure pour les mêmes faits
suivants c'est plus facile au début
quand même c'est plus facile au début
dans la mesure où déjà pour commencer
les joueurs enchaînent à peu près 10
coups qu'ils connaissent par coeur
suivi de cinq coups qui connaissent très
bien donc en fait ils jouent les 15
premiers coups ont à peu près dix
minutes
donc là on peut dire que cram nick n'est
pas dans le bon timing n'est pas dans le
bon tempo
mais d'un autre côté il faut choisir
entre jouer vite et jouais bien ce n'est
malheureusement pas compatible non à
divers kramnik préfère jouer bien à
noter que dans ce match les deux joueurs
préfèrent jouer bien ne préfère pas
mettre la pression autant il ne préfère
pas prendre de risque
des échecs plus en fait il s'agirait
tout l'intérieur de ce type de match et
de callas c'est des échecs du jeu
d'échecs pure et dure et dure
contrairement aux échecs rapide qui sont
plus disons sportif sportif émotionnel
puisque la la pendule joue un rôle
vraiment très très important et les
gaffes sont fréquents quel retournement
de situation aussi voilà dans les
parties longues les retournements de
situation sont beaucoup moins
monnaie courante et beaucoup moins
fréquents évidemment les joueurs quand
ils ont le temps de réfléchir
jouons général le meilleur coup il faut
bien le dire ce sont les meilleurs
joueurs du monde et il joue les
meilleurs coups ça paraît assez logique
chronique jette un oeil furtif à la
pendule
ouais la cram nique
il ne bouge plus il a l'air seringue
ils ne bougent plus du tout serein quand
même là les reçoit que se passe-t-il
dans la tête de vladimir kramnik l'un
des meilleurs joueurs du monde
le numéro 2 en ce moment il est en train
d'envisager toutes les variantes qui
découlent du couteau d'éviter aussi ce
sacrifice d'options de garry kasparov
vladimir kramnik est en train de tout
vérifier
il veut être sûr de son coup avant une
sûr de son fait avant de permettre ces
possibilités
il doit également cherché une solution
de secours une solution qui lui
permettrait de garder la position telle
qu'elle est pendant quelques coups
encore pour différer un peu les
complications la chronique est en train
d'hésiter
est ce que j'y vais tout de suite ou est
ce que j'attends un peu en tout cas la
balle est dans son camp
se pose la question grave ni tour des
huit il doit calculer ça alors peut-être
qu'on peut regarder voilà ici les autres
possibilités pour les noirs toro 8
peut-être tour vite c'est un autre coup
possible on va le mentionner sap à leers
a pas l'air très très puissant taureau 8
quand même battu robin c'est pas un très
joli coup ont effectivement ce n'est pas
un coup qu'on a envie de jouer
makhtal à tour s'active un peu mais ils
ont que la elle fait rien de spécial est
bouchée par le cavalier façon le pion
aux scènes qu il est quand même très
très jolis plans sur les ramenaient qui
manie très jolies places en crèche doit
regarder à peu près le public qui doit
avoir fait entrer le public dans son
champ dans son champ de vision
tout rebit donc rappelons qu'on est ori
versa studio à londres et que la salle
est pleine tout simplement le public est
en délire
ouais les clubs anglais sont venus
nombreux pour regarder ce spectacle là
dinars a indiqué garry kasparov sont
devant une salle pleine et ça ne leur
arrive pas systématiquement
oui puisque d'habitude les tournois sont
des tournois où il ya non pas deux
joueurs comme la c1 match donc le
tournant c'est plutôt 10 10 joueurs huit
joueurs et se déroule très peu souvent
dans des endroits où il ya des places
pour le public
pour des questions de coût ne serait ce
que deux coups puisque les matchs de la
soie c'est long la main de chronique ça
dure une semaine ou deux un tournoi est
donc louer un théâtre pour deux semaines
c'est quand même assez cher
oui je pense pas que ce soit
spécialement une question une question
d'argent mais simplement comment
oui c'est possible c'est tout à fait
possible
le fait est que vladimir kramnik et en
méditation complète
j'y vais j'y vais pas là c'est tout
l'enjeu de son prochain coup son
prochain coup qui peut donc mettre la
partie sur un terrain calme et
positionnelle ou kasparov conservera une
petite initiative ou alors mettre le feu
à l'échiquier directement puisque il n'y
a aucun doute sur ton des huit garry
kasparov a plongé et va jouer le coup au
5 e 6 puisqu'une kasparov doivent
prendre des risques
tordre et 8 kasparov a prévu le sync
tour des huit autour vie tels sont les
choix de vladimir kramnik dans cette
position a priori n'a que deux solutions
peut-être qu'il va en trouver une autre
la main il active et toutes ces pièces
kasparov la mine de rien quand même
toutes ces pièces sont actives elles
disent toutes le centre foulée 2 contre
le 5e tour d un tour eu un quart les f3
contre le 5 et le cavalier des 5es pas
sélectionné au centre on peut dire qu'il
a il à optimiser la position de ces
pièces kasparov il peut pas faire mieux
il ne peut pas faire mieux mais comme on
l'avait dit déjà dans la première partie
qui avait à peu près un même schéma
ce qu'il faut dire c'est que un jeu de
pièces vraisemblablement ne suffit pas
ici normalement les blancs devraient
jouer avec leurs pions mais c'est ce
qu'on va voir cercle à la dernière fois
on fait kasparov a essayé de jouer à
baisser depuis on n'a pas réussi
il a peut-être choisi le plan tout
simplement de différent de m
pression avec les pièces alors il a
quand même été aidé pour ça dans la
mesure où cram nique à cette fois ci me
s'en fout sur la 4c 6 ce qui n'est quand
même pas la meilleure case on
préférerait bien entendu que le fou soit
sur la case de 6 dans cette position
pour les pour les noirs et pourquoi
c'est très clair la différence c'est
justement qu'ils auraient pas secouer e
5 e 6 qui libère tout le potentiel des
pièces blanches mias arabi aussi
peut-être que les noirs pouvaient jouer
aussi c7 c6 pour chasser le caler des
cinq autres possibilités effectivement
donc là kasparov a utilisé un nombre de
coups malin qui a empêché kamnik de
mettre le foin aussi ce qui lui a forcé
avec le fou là bas
chronique n'a pas assumé ses
responsabilités et n'a pas joué pour un
f3 et ici il est en train sur une
position avec une mauvaise disposition
de pièces contre garry kasparov web est
encore une fois comment disait faut deux
faiblesses pour gagner là les blancs
monts quand même un avantage donc à une
faiblesse noir c'est que il ya quatre
contre trois d'un côté c'est tout c'est
tout comme un peu faible elle n'a jeté
un oeil dans la pendule un charnier 1h02
du reste 1h02 kramnik hymne est joué 17
coups donc il lui reste une heure deux
pour jouer veille trois coups avant
d'avoir une heure de plus de réflexion
non mais là attention parce que je vais
23 coups facile à dire
encore faut-il ne pas perdre ah oui bien
sûr c'est pour ça qu'il réfléchit c'est
parce que sa position commence à être
pas si simple réveillée sous pression il
faut dire que les pièces blanches vous
mettre la pression maximale
elles sont toutes placées pour mettre
une pression centrale maximale sur les
noirs alors stéphane tout de suite je
vais les voir dans la salle puisque pour
l'instant on n'a pas encore vu les
seconds ont des joueurs mais ce que sur
eux on ne sait pas s'il est ce qu on
danse on l'a peut-être sur aussi ce
crâne que jouer f6 non non ça c'est pas
c'est envisageable mais à mon avis ce
n'est pas une bonne opération donc je
vais me renseigner dans la salle voir
s'il ya des seconds ans qui sont
visibles voir si à ce genre de choses et
voir si tout va bien à la technique
en attendant je vous laisse donc avec
stéphane laborde aux commentaires et
crame qui réfléchit
thil ou non mettre le feu à l'échiquier
dans cette position c'est son choix et
il va le faire la chronique en grande
réflexion c'est le moment c'est le
moment clé probablement de la partie
au niveau du déclenchement des
hostilités sur la position puisque le
coup suivant nos chroniques va provoquer
probablement un coût qui peut être
violent nos kasparov c'est à dire le
coup eux 5 e 6 on coud qui commencent à
mettre le feu sur l'échiquier donc là
crown il doit bien calculer toutes les
conséquences du coup par exemple du coup
tour des huit ils peuvent autour des
huit tours 8 on voit pas trop d'autres
coups intéressants peut-être cavaler g6
est envisageable qu'elle g6 n'empêche
pas peut-être aussi ce aussi ce qui crée
des faiblesses dans le camp noir puisque
après puis on prend 1,6 tout reprend le
6 le cas et j'ai six et attaquer il faut
qu'il trouve une case et il n'a pas
beaucoup il y en a pas beaucoup
ça a l'air d'être difficile pour
krasniqi silure est une heure il y as tu
une heure à une heure moins d'une heure
à chronique
il reste moins d'une heure à chronique
ça y est 59 minutes il est en difficulté
chronique est en difficulté sur cette
partie maintenant bon si ils crament dit
que trouve les bons coups il peut
ensuite éventuellement dérouler la suite
sans grande difficulté mais pour
l'instant
alors petite interruption petite
interruption momentanée
voilà nous continuons donc le direct
stéphane laborde va revenir pour
l'instant il a il a un travail très
urgent donc ce qui ne fait quelque chose
qui l'empêchera donc de faire les
commentaires pour le moment
donc voilà superbes images toujours
vladimir kramnik en pleine réflexion il
va choisir il doit choisir
il ne lui reste que 58 minutes mais
c'est quand même beaucoup
ça veut dire que le moment est tellement
critique que vladimir kramnik estime
qu'il doit réfléchir qu'il doit prendre
son temps que celles au moment du choix
le moment critique de cette partie là
c'est vraiment un des moments les plus
importants de cette troisième partie du
match c'est la première fois également
qu'il va y avoir des complications
terrible qui peuvent survenir
puisque dans les deux parties qui ont
précédé
garry kasparov n'a pas réussi à
entraîner cramique sur le terrain
tactique
le jeu a été purement stratégique ici
peut-être pour la première fois dans ce
match
une position sauvage est extrêmement
complexe va survenir
c'est ce que craint munich est en train
de vérifier ils essaient d'en analyser
les conséquences mais c'est très très
difficile
à noter quand même que kasparov est un
spécialiste du jeu tactique
kasparov est probablement l'homme qui
calcule le mieux sur terre le qui
calcule le plus rapidement qu'ils
n'oublient pratiquement jamais rien
s'est il est très connu pour ça donc la
cram nick est très très chaud il doit
faire très attention puisque s'il ya la
moindre erreur la moindre faille dans
ses calculs
kasparov va trouver kasparov va tout de
suite mettre le doigt sur le problème et
ça c'est intolérable puisque ça peut
aboutir à une défaite express c'est pas
très bon pour le moral si kramnik oublie
quelque chose et c'est très possible
parce qu'il va y avoir une position je
vais vous expliquer concrètement ce que
ça veut dire une position sauvage ça
veut dire que les bleus ont cinq
possibilité d' attaque sur quoi les
noirs auront cinq défense possible sur
quoi il y aura cinq nouvelles
possibilités d'attac encore 5 défense
donc si vous multipliez tout ça on est
très vite à plus de 1500 positions
possibles et là
ça commence à devenir du calcul
d'ordinateurs du calcul informatique
l'envoi la position et on rappelle donc
que tour des 8es la première possibilité
qu'ils enverraient des grosses grosses
complications après le coup 18 aux 6es
également il faut mentionner que
chronique peut jouer après 17 trous 1
donc dans cette position pour que c'est
à lui tout est sous la pression sur
laquelle réfléchit au lieu de tourner
vite jouée tours 8
avec quelque chose de beaucoup plus
calme